greg if this goes to the Supreme Court
it will depend very much on whether we
have eight justices or nine justices
when it does the outcome that we see
Willis yeah well there's two things to
we want to keep separate first there's
what we're talking about this weekend
the tolit was talking about the
temporary block of this this policy
that's going to come up to the Supreme
Court probably in a matter of days and
it will be an eight-member Supreme Court
and whoever loses at the appeals court
level which is where it is right now is
going to need five votes there then the
broader questions about you know the
president's constitutional power is
power under federal statutes that may
take a little longer to get to the
quarter we may well have nine members
including a justice course H by that
time help us understand the the history
and notoriety of the Ninth Circuit Greg
this is a this is a circuit that is
known for being more liberal than others
it is well deserved it gets reversed by
the Supreme Court over the years has
been reversed a disproportionate number
of times now that's in part because it's
also a very huge circuit in addition to
California of course it has Washington
state which is where they order from a
federal judge came on friday and the
panel that is considering this this
issue that arose over the weekend has
two Democratic appointees one Republican
appointee we don't want to assume that's
how they're going to come out but that
does suggest that there might be some
leanings there so once again we have a
tweet from Donald term that we're going
to bring up the president weeding out
the opinion of the so-called judge which
essentially takes law enforcement away
from our country is ridiculous and will
be overturned tolu I mean there's no
precedent for a jharia a president sort
of attacking the judiciary like this is
there well we've definitely seen a
president Trump take an unconventional
approach to the presidency and that
includes specifically with its Twitter
account which is unleashed attacks on a
number of different people in this case
a federal judge he has seen some
backlash from some of his Republican
supporters saying that that's maybe
crossing the line by attacking the
member of the independent judiciary but
he was supported by his vice president
who on the sunday shows said that you
know the president is frustrated and
he's communicating in the way that he
normally does with his
supporters who appreciate his
plain-spoken approach that just saying
what's on his mind and obviously he's
not happy with what this judge did and
he believes that it will eventually be
overturned